SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER IN RESPONSE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ONE OR TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH.
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PROCESS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THE TIME WILL BE A MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOT READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC FACT
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. AARON
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEET MEETING SERVICE
ARE HAVE THESE CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS AND THAT'S CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LACK TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE. OUR
TECHNOLOGY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. WE
HAVE EIGHT BILL EIGHT BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THREE BILLS ARE
ON CONSENT BILLS BILLS ARE AB
FIVE FOUR SIX. A. B. ELEVEN
FORTY AND AB TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE. AND LET'S STARTBY IT
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. PORTATO
HERE JONES. CORTESE YOUR-
KAMLAGER YOUR- TEN. WE HAVE A
CORE. SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH- A
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE'S OUR
FIRST AUTHOR YEAH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CALDERON IF YOU WANT TO
COME UP AND PRESENT AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FOUR FOUR FIVE
WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
AGENDA ITEM THREE AN AGENDA
ITEM FOR. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR FOUR FIVE REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS NEED TO COLLECT
PERSONAL PARENTAL INFORMATION
AS A CONDITION FOR PROVIDING
SERVICE. REGIONAL CENTERS OR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT COORDINATE SERVICES FOR
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES-
FEDERAL FUNDING RULES REQUIRE
THEM TO COLLECT PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM PARENTS. IN
ORDER TO SERVE THEIR CHILDREN
THESE RULES CHANGED YEARS AGO
BUT STATE LAW HAS NOT. REGIONAL
CENTERS DON'T NEED THIS
INFORMATION AND NO FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE TIED TO IT. AB FOUR
FOUR FIVE REPEALS THE OUTDATED
REQUIREMENTS REMOVING A SMALL
BUT SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
SERVICE AND ELIMINATES A
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLE HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS AMY
WEST LANE FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF RGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES AND
GLORIA WONG FROM EASTERN LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL CENTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY WHAT'S
GOING ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB FOUR FOUR
FIVE. AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CALDERON NOTED THIS IS A BILL
THAT WOULD HELP REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR ACCESS FOR PEOPLE. YOU MAY
NOT HAVE PERSONAL INFORMATION
LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
READILY AVAILABLE AND WILLING
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
RESULT IN ORDER TO GAIN ACCESS
TO THOSE CRITICAL SERVICES FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. WE WANT TO
THANK. ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALDERON
FOR AGREEING TO AUTHORED THIS
BILL AND I WILL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO GLORIA WONG. DIRECTOR
OF EASTERN LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
CENTER TO SHARE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MY NAME IS GLORIA HUANG I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
EASTERN LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
CENTER THERE ARE TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH SERVE OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS REGIONAL
CENTERS PROVIDE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES SH
EASTERN LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
CENTER NOW REFER TO US AS THE
LORD GOD AS AN ACRONYM IS ONE
OF THE SEVEN. REGIONAL CENTERS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND IT
SERVES APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS ARE UNIQUE
DEMOGRAPHICS INCLUDE 71%
HISPANIC FAMILIES AND 13% IS
REPRESENTED BY OUR ASIAN
COMMUNITY WE REPRESENT PARTS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALDERON
SHOULD DISTRICT. ON A REGULAR
BASIS WE FIND THAT INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES SEEKING REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES DO NOT ALWAYS
FOLLOW THROUGH AFTER THE
INITIAL INTAKE MEETING. FAMILY
SIMPLY STOPPED RESPONDING AND
IT IS BELIEVED THAT THIS DROP
OFF IS IKELY THE RESULT OF
PRIVACY CONCERNS. THERE WAS A
CASE THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH
WHERE A MOTHER WHO WAS GOING
THROUGH THE ELIGIBILITY PROCESS
FOR HER TEENAGE SON. SHE SURE
THAT THE SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
HAD REFERRED HER TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER BECAUSE YOUR
SON WAS EXHIBITING BEHAVIOR
SIMILAR TO THAT OF A PERSON
WITH AUTISM. MOTHER SHARED THAT
HER SON HAD NO FRIENDS OFTEN
WAS BULLIED AND THAT HE WOULD
PUT HIMSELF IN AND SAFE
PREDICAMENTS DUE TO THE
UNFILTERED COMMENTS HE MADE
TOWARDS OTHER STUDENTS. SHE
FEARED FOR HER SON'S SAFETY
INVESTORS DESPERATELY WANTED TO
ACTIONS REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. SHE STRUGGLED BETWEEN
ACCESSING MUCH NEEDED SERVICES
FOR HER SON BUT ALSO FOR YOUR
DISCLOSURE OF YOUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND WHAT
RAMIFICATIONS WOULD RESULT FROM
THAT DISCLOSURE. SH AB FOUR
FOUR FIVE THREE MOVES THIS YEAR
BY REQUIRING AND NEEDED
PERSONAL INFORMATION FAMILY
SIMPLY CHOOSE NOT TO REGISTERED
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER THIS
MEANS A TRIAL LIKE THE ONE I'VE
JUST DESCRIBED WILL GO WITHOUT
CRITICALLY NEEDED SERVICES THAT
HE OR SHE IS ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AND PASS AB FOUR FOUR FIVE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON FOR ALL DURING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY- AT THE SMALL
WILL OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
FOUR FIVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CALDERON. AND SADDAM HERE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE PHONE LINES ARE
IN THE ROOM FIRST. YES I MY
APOLOGIES- WE WILL BEGIN HERE.
IN THE ROOM AND SEEN. NO ONE.
NO ONE WANTS TO TESTIFIED NO
ONE HERE WILL MOVE ON TO TWENTY
FORTY. AND SEE NO ONE THERE ARE
MOVING ON TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC CLIENT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IT IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO. HELP PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
BILL AB FOUR FOUR FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME IN EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR AB. FOUR
FOUR FIVE. AND OUR FIRST
PARTICIPANT WILL COME FROM LINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TREATING ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE ARC IN UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR BILL AB.
FOUR FOUR FIVE. M. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU AT THIS MOMENT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL
MOVE ON TO A PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. THREE NINE
MOVING ON TO TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE'S WHILE AND NOW ON THE
TELEPHONE LINES THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
FIVE. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION AND
AB FOUR FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL A. B.
FOUR FOUR FIVE. MADAM CHAIR
THERE'S NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE
AT THE SMALL WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON IT BEFORE FOR
FIVE. SENATOR PAN OF MOVE THE
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION- ON A
BEFORE FOR FIVE. SKINNER
THERMOSTAT SENATOR TOM LONGER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I KNOW
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY BUT I ACTUALLY DO
HAVE BROADER ISSUES WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND MAYBE THIS
IS SOMETHING THIS BILL IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES BUT- IT
DOES REVOLVE AROUND AND I
ACTUALLY HAVE A THREE OF THEM
IN MY DISTRICT- BUT THE
INCONSISTENCY WITH WHICH THE
EACH OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE RUN. AND HOW THEY MAKE
AVAILABLE THE RESOURCES TO
THEIR CLIENTS HOW THEY MAKE
AVAILABLE ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEIR CLIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THESE ARE FAMILIES
THAT ARE OFTEN TIME MOST IN
NEED- IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
STATES. AND ARE INCREDIBLY
DEPENDENT ON THE INTEGRITY OF
THAT PARTICULAR REGIONAL CENTER
TO GIVE THEM THE FULL MENU OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
RATHER THAN PARSING THEM OUT.
BASED ON WHAT THEY FEEL THEY
WANT TO OFFER OR THE KIND OF
VENDOR THAT THEY FEEL THEY WANT
TO MAKE AVAILABLE TO THE FAMILY
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES THOSE
THINGS I THINK IT WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THEM BUT SINCE YOU'RE
WITNESSES ACTUALLY FROM ONE OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS IT WAS
INCUMBENT UPON ME TO LET HER
KNOW AND YOU AS THE AUTHOR NOW
THAT THERE ARE LARGE ISSUES- IN
OUR DISABILITY COMMUNITY AS IT
RELATES TO OUR REGIONAL CENTERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SEE A
CENTER COMMAS THAT JUST TO
COMMENT RIGHT OKAY. THAT'S FINE
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
TO HER- THANK YOU SENATOR- I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING UP YOUR
CONCERNS- THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
TO ME AND I'LL MAKE SURE TO
DISCUSS THEM WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL THANK YOU FOR BEING
THOUGHTFUL. I APPRECIATED. AND
I'D LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY IS THAT
YOUR CLOSING YEAH OKAY GREAT.
OKAY SO- WE HAVE A MOTION ON A
BEFORE FOR FIVE- IN CONSULTING
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOUR FOUR FIVE DO PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FURTADO I. FOR TADO I'D JONES
COURTESY. KAMLAGER KAMARG ARE
AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE. WE WILL
HOLD FACT A BILL TO ALLOW
OTHERS. VOTE ON IT. BUT AND
THEN NEXT UP BY AGENDA ITEM TO
AB SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CLARIFIES THAT
FAMILY REUNIFICATION SERVICES
NOT BE BYPASSED IF A PARENT
WITH A DRUG ADDICTION SUFFERS A
RELAPSE AFTER SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING DRUG TREATMENT.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STUDY NEARLY 8% OF CALIFORNIANS
MET THE CRITERIA FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER RELAPSES ARE
REGULAR OCCURRENCE IN
REHABILITATION JOURNEYS
INCLUDING IN INDIVIDUALS
ACTIVELY SEEKING TREATMENT. IF
A FAMILY BECOMES INVOLVED WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THEY
SHOULD NOT AUTOMATICALLY LOSE
ACCESS TO REUNIFICATION
SERVICES IF A PARENT HAS
RELAPSED. THIS BILL PASSED OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY UNANIMOUSLY AND
HAS TO OPPOSITION. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT
R. JULIA HANNIGAN FROM
DEPENDENCY LEGAL SERVICES AND
AT HOWARD FROM THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE. MODERATED
WE HAVE VIA. WITNESSES ON THE
CALL. PLEASE YEAH WITNESSES ARE
YET TO DO IT ON YOUR PHONE
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU SENATORS FOR GIVING ME TIME
TO SPEAK MY NAME IS JULIE HIM
AGAIN AND I AM LEAD PARENTS
TURNING IN ON THE COUNTY. AND
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
DEPENDENCY LEGAL SERVICES
REPRESENTS PARENTS AND CHILDREN
IN CHILD WELFARE PROCEEDINGS IN
EIGHT COUNTIES ACROSS NORTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT CHILDREN DO BEST WITH
THEIR FAMILY. EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD CODIFY
RECENT APPELLATE COURT DECISION
IN RIGHT B. E. AND CLARIFY THAT
A PARENT CANNOT BE DENIED
REUNIFICATION. BECAUSE WHAT HAS
BEEN DEEMED PASSIVE RESISTANCE
TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
ESSENTIALLY THAT MEANS THAT
PARENTS WHO HAVE SUCCEEDED IN
TREATMENT IN THE PAST BUT IT
SIMPLY RELAXED. WOULD BE GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REUNIFY WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. THIS PARTICULAR
CHANGE SIMPLY RULING. OUT THE
JUDICIALLY CREATED DOCTRINE OF
PASSIVE RESISTANCE RETURNS THE
STATUTE TO ITS ORIGINAL MEANING
A GIVE COURT THE AUTHORITY TO
LOOK AT EACH FAMILY. AND
IDENTIFY WHETHER A PARENT HAS
TRULY REDUCE TO TREATMENT OR IF
YOU SIMPLY HAD TO STUMBLE IN
THEIR SOBRIETY. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS COMPORTS WITH THE SCIENCE
BEHIND DRUG TREATMENT. WE KNOW
THAT RELAPSE IS COMMON EVEN FOR
THOSE IN LONG TERM SOBRIETY.
PLEASE CHANGE WILL ALSO PROVIDE
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES SHOULD BE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REUNITE
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD ENSURE THAT
RELAXES NOT MEAN THAT A PARENT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO LOSING
THEIR CHILDREN FOREVER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. HI GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
HALOGEN OR COUNCIL OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE
LIKEWISE PLEASE BECAUSE SPONSOR
A BILL WHICH WE BELIEVE STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
EMPOWERING JUDGES TO PROTECT
CHILDREN THE ANSWERS ARE
FAMILIES BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL FACTS EACH CASE OF
THE JUDGES ONCE AGAIN AND COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT HIGHWAYS.
NOT RESISTING WHEN IT COMES TO.
AUG ALCOHOLICS. WITHOUT AND
WITH THINGS YOUR COMMITTEES.
REALLY CLICKING OFFICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- THANK
YOU AT THIS MOMENT WILL OPEN IT
UP TO PUBLIC COMMENTED SUPPORT
BEGIN IN AND ROOM FOR FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE SEE NON MOVING ON TO
TWENTY FORTY. NONE THERE IS
WELL ON'T FUNDRAISER CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR BILL
A. B. SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IN
ONE FELL BY ZERO ANY KICHI
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER. NO PLACE YOU BACK INTO
THE QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THEN AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR. SB SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. ONE
MOMENT MADAM CHAIR. WE DO HAVE
A PARTISAN QUEUING UP. THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING THE DAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT. AND
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOUR ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- AT THIS MOMENT
WILL MOVE ON TO LEAVE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BUT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF.
A. B. R. SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT-
BEGINNING IN ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. NON THERE'S WELL.
AND NOW ON TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE FOR THOSE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
OF. CALLERS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. GREAT THANK YOU- I
AM I WANT TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS BEFORE I ALLOW YOU
KNOW OF BEFORE GIVING THE MIKE
TO OTHERS- TO COMMENT ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I WANT TO START
OFF BY APPRECIATE IT TOO AND
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR AND-
THE GOAL. THAT **** INTENDS
WITH THIS BILL TO CLARIFY WHEN
PARENTS INVOLVED IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM- AND THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR REUNIFICATION
SERVICES I JUST WANT TO GO ON
THE RECORD NOTING THAT THE
PROVISION OF THE SERVICES.
SORRY THE V. REUNIFICATION- I
JUST WANNA GO ON THE RECORD
NOTING THAT THE PROVISION OF
THE SERVICES DOES NOT GUARANTEE
REUNIFICATION AS ALWAYS THE
COURT WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION WHETHER TO RE
UNIFIER TERMINATE PARENTAL
RIGHTS BASED ON THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD WHEN
MAKING THESE DECISIONS THE
COURT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT A
BROAD ARRAY OF FACTORS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE PARENTS PARTICIPATION IN
COURT ORDERED REUNIFICATION
SERVICES SUCH AS DRUG OR
ALCOHOL TREATMENT- THE BILL
SEEKS TO CODIFY A RECENT COURT
DECISION IN ORDER TO GIVE. THE
COURTS MORE CLARITY ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THE
COURT CAN DENY REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. HOWEVER I WORRY THAT
THE TERM PASSIVE RESISTANCE
WITH NO FURTHER EXPLANATION AS
USED IN THIS BILL AND THE
RELEVANT COURT DECISION MAY NOT
HAVE. THE CLARIFYING FACT
INTENDED BY THE AUTHOR- IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHOR INTENDS TO CONTINUE%
WORKING WITH A STAKEHOLDERS TO
CLARIFY THIS PRIOR TO THE BILL
BEING IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- SO I'LL BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL TODAY BUT WILL BE
CLOSELY WATCHING FOR THE
CLARIFICATION AS THE BILL MOVES
TO THE SENATE. AND RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE- MY BILL ON THE
FLOOR- ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT AND ALL MOVE ON
TO OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE'LL
START WITH OUR VICE CHAIR.
THANK OU MA'AM JERRY AND I
JUST WANT TO GIVE THAT I HAD
THE SAME CONCERN I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO COUNTRY. TO JUDICIARY
IS ALSO WHICH I SAID I'M- SORRY
I DIDN'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
RESPOND INTO THAT TODAY OR IF.
ARE YOU KNOW I BUT I CAN SAY
SENATOR AND I APPRECIATE- YOU
BRINGING THIS HAPPEN IT'S- VERY
IMPORTANT AND- I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS-
TO MAKE THIS A BETTER POLICY-
SORRY I GIVE YOU MY COMMITMENT
ON THAT. YEAH I THINK I'M IN
THE SAME BOAT I'M GONNA VOTE
FOR TODAY- AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
EXPECTATION WHY WOULDN'T GET IN
TAKE CARE BYE JUDICIARY BUT
LET'S WILL SIT THERE TOO
THANKS. THANK YOU. AND CENTER
PAN. THANK THANK YOU AND
SENECA. CALDERON I ACTUALLY
THINK THIS IS GOOD POLICY- AND-
DO WE ARE TRACKING ABOUT HOW DO
WE KEEP KIDS SAFE FOR QUEEN DO
WHAT'S BEST FOR THE KIDS- I
THINK THE- ISSUE IS JUST TRY TO
SORT OUT EXACTLY THE RIGHT
LEGAL LANGUAGE TO CAPTURE YOUR
TRUE INTENT SO THAT THERE ISN'T
A- LACK OF CLARITY- ONCE- I.
WOULD SAY I HOPE THIS BECOMES
SIGNED INTO LAW- SO CERTAINLY
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY FLIPBOARD TO JUDICIARY'S
S. EXPERTISE AND SAME FOR ANY
REFINEMENT THE LANGUAGE I AM
PLEASED TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR OF
COURSE THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AM
WE HAVE A MOTION- AB. BUT YOU
LIKE TO A CLOSE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CALDERON OKAY MADAM CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU OKAY OUR CONSULTING
KEY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PAS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY HER TADO. I TITLE I'D
JONES JONES BY CORTESE.
KAMLAGER AND BY AN ONLINE. OKAY
WE WILL HOLD THAT A BILL TO
ALLOW OTHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON THE MEASURE AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXTAGENDA ITEM
WHICH IS AGENDA ITEM THREE A.
B. ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR AND
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS AB ONE ZERO
ZERO FOUR EXTENDS THE DECENNIAL
CENSUS INCOME EXEMPTION FOR CAL
WORKS. RECIPIENTS AND REQUIRES
THAT THE EXEMPTION BE
RETROACTIVE. EVERY TEN YEARS
THE US CENSUS BUREAU RECRUITS
TEMPORARY WORKERS TO SUPPORT
THE DECENNIAL CENSUS. AS A
RESULT OF THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC TEMPORARY CENSUS
EMPLOYMENT HAS EXTENT EXTENDED
INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
FEDERAL MINISTRATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES HAS
ENCOURAGED STATES. TO DISREGARD
THIS INCOME IN THE CALCULATION
OF ELIGIBILITY FOR PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CAL WORKS. AB ONE
THOUSAND FOUR ALIGNS WITH THIS
RECOMMENDATION AND ENSURES THAT
THE CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS. CAN
CONTINUE CENSUS EFFORTS WITHOUT
FEAR OF LOSING PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR IS
ROBERT SMITH FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE HAPPENING
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS ROBERT
SMITH MEMBER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LEGISLATION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES. WE BROUGHT THIS
PROPOSAL TO THE AUTHORS
ATTENTION BECAUSE THE COW WORKS
CENTER SECTION. ESTABLISHED BY
AB YOU KNOW SEVEN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN. ONLY AUTHORIZED
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
DELAY THEM SPENT COUNTLESS OF
SUPPORT FOR CHARACTERS THAT
HAVE CONTINUED INTO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ACCORDING THIS BILL
ALLOWS YOUR ANYTIME PRESENTED
BECOME RECEIVED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ALSO BE ACCEPTED
FROM THE TOWERS CORRECT
CALCULATION. THE LANGUAGE ALSO
ENSURES THAT FUTURE SENTENCE
WORK SIMILARLY EXEMPTED FOR
FROM THE GROUT CALCULATION ON
THE CURRENT THANK YOU OUT
THERE- WORK ON THIS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION HAVE. TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU- THIS MOMENT. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES FOR THIS BILL. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE ZERO ZERO
FOUR AND AGAIN IN A ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. C. NINE MOVIE NOT
TO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. SEE NON-
MOVING ONTO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. FOR THOSE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR.
MODERATE BY IN SUPPORT. YES FOR
A TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TIM ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE CHILD BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
A BI TEN ZERO FOUR. WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE. MOMENT. ONE
MOMENT. IT WILL BE MARKED WITH
THIS MOMENTARILY AS WE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SIXTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. GIVEN THE WATER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TECH AND- FOR THANK YOU. THE
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR CHANNEL FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AT THIS MOMENT TO- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION BUT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BEGIN
IN A ROOM FORTY TWO THREE A C.
NINE. A ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ON
THERE AS WELL. AND NOW THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
FOR THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY COLORS.
THAT AT THIS TIME- TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. TEN ZERO
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO INITIAL YOUR
OPPOSITION- AB ONE ZERO ZERO
FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE RETURNING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE- WE'LL WE'LL DO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION WILL BEGIN WITH
A- SENATOR PLAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- ANS AMERICA CALDERON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- AS ONE OF THE CO
CHAIRS OF OUR SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS WE KNEW
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS TO. BE
ABLE TO RECRUIT PEOPLE TO HELP
REACH OUT PEOPLE ACTUALLY FROM
THE COMMUTE SELF FOR TO BUILD
TRUST AND INCLUDES- PEOPLE WHO.
WHO MAY BE DEPENDENT ON STATE
SERVICES LIKE HOW IT WORKS AND
THEY SHOULD CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T
HAVE. THE DISADVANTAGED JUST
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY HELPED
OUT WITH THE THEIR CIVIC DUTY
BY REACHING OUT TO PEOPLE WHO
FOR AND PERFORMING CENSUS THESE
ARE TEMPORARY JOBS AS WELL SO
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT- AND-
CERTAINLY- YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORD AND WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO
BUILD THE PERFECT TIME. THANK
YOU. AT MISTER WESTRUP THANK
YOU THANK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M
I'M I DON'T KNOW IF YOU NOTICED
IN THE NOW SAYS I'M THE ONLY
SENATOR THAT VOTED AGAINST- AB
EIGHT OH SEVEN LAST YEAR. AND
I'M I'M I'M THEN THE RECESSION
ASSEMBLY I'M REALLY CONFLICTED
ON THIS AND SO- OR I SEE THE
VALUE OF HAVING SOMEBODY TAKE A
TEMPORARY JOB AND NOT BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY MAKING
THAT DECISION I SUPPORT. AND
MAYBE OR YOUR WITNESS CAN HELP
ME OUT YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT IN
OTHER SITUATIONS. THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY DEALING WITH THE
CENSUS MAYBE SOMEBODY TAKES A
PART TIME JOB AT CHRISTMAS
TIME. TO WORK SEASONALLY YOU
KNOW FOR A IN THE IN THE-
BUSINESS ASPECT OR TAKES A
SUMMER JOB. YOU KNOW- MAYBE
LIFEGUARDING OR YOU KNOW
WORKING ARE THOSE TYPES OF JOBS
ALSO EXCLUDED EXEMPTED FROM
THIS TYPE OF A SITUATION LIKE
WE'RE DOING HERE WITH THE
CENSUS DO NO. I DON'T NOMINATE
DEFERRED ROBERT SMITH OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
SENATOR THIS IS ROBERT SMITH
AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT- I THINK
IT REALLY KIND OF DEPENDS ON
WHETHER OR NOT. THE CALL. THE
AGREEMENT CAN BE READ AT THE
END OF THAT IS. THIS IS THE
RECIPIENT RECEIVING THAT CAN
WORK CAN EXPECT. THAT THE
INCOME OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS- GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE CENTERS BUT THE WORK IS
TENDS TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE-
INCONSISTENT. AND SO GENERALLY
UNDER CAL WORK THROUGH THE
WALLS AND THEN UNDER FEDERAL.
RULES ON THE WARDENS REALLY
EXPECT THAT- ATTEMPTED TO COME
COULD BE ANTICIPATED BUT THIS
BILL PROVIDES CLARITY AND
PROVIDE THAT ASSURANCE THAT
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE HELPING OUT
WITH THE U. S. CENSUS AND ALSO
COURT GETTING VALUABLE WORK
EXPERIENCE. OR CERTAIN THAT
THAT. THAT MARK BEHALF OF THE
SIMPLEST ISN'T GOING TO END TO
THEIR TO SOLDIERS BUILDING.
OKAY OUR MISSION IS TO TRY READ
WITH. BILL OBVIOUSLY MAKES IS
EXPLICIT FOR. THE US CENSUS BUT
WHAT IF I UNDERSTOOD YOUR
BEGINNING PART OF IT REGARDING
BUSINESS AND TEMPORARY.
SEASONAL JOBS IS IT'S UNCLEAR
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THE CURRENT LAWS ON CLEAR. THAT
NO IT DEPENDS ON THE TYPE OF
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING SO
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S IF THEY'RE
TAKING IN PLYMOUTH THAT IS
CONSISTENT AND THAT THEY CAN
ANTICIPATE A CERTAIN LEVEL
INCOME. THAT IS COUNTED TOWARDS
THEIR POWER. IT'S NOT THAT THE
VERY TEMPORARY- THE LEVEL WAGES
THEY CANNOT. AND THEY COUNT IT
TOOK OF DEPENDS ON THE TYPE OF
JOB THAT YOU'RE TO KEEP. OKAY
THANK YOU- OKAY I WITH ALL
EMILY OFF TODAY AND MAYBE- WHAT
IS A GOOD APPROACH FROM HERE IS
IT IS IT THEY CLOSED
APPROPRIATIONS FROM HERE IS
THAT CORRECT. OKAY- AND SO
MAYBE I CAN GET GET THERE THEN
SO THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE DYESS. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
HI YES AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- AND THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. AB ONE
ZERO ZERO FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HER TADO. JONES NOT VOTING.
CORTESE HI. KAMLAGER PAN BY
ANTI I NEED TO REPEAT COURT-
JONES WAS NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU AND I HAVE A
BILL UP IN A LABOR RIGHT NOW SO
SHOULD SHALL I PASSED THE GAVEL
TO CENTER PAN. OKAY. OKAY THAT
IS A- WHAT WAS YOUR OLD ADDRESS
YOU. ALL RIGHT SO NEXT UP IS.
NEXT UP IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BY A
SUMMER RUBIO I HOPEFULLY- I
WILL CHAIR WELL ENOUGH TO MAKE
IT WORTH YOUR- I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT I'M NOT CHANGED- ALL
RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT DAY
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH I A
FOLLOW UP MEASURE FROM OUR
EFFORTS LAST YEAR RELATING TO
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTERS ARE
CA SEES. ARE LONGTIME PARTY OF
MINE HAS BEEN THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES TO NEGLECT THE
NEGLECTED CHILDREN AND
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE IN
DIFFICULT OR ABUSIVE SITUATIONS
LAST YEAR I WAS PROUD TO AUTHOR
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH AND
COORDINATE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES AT
MEDICAL PROVIDERS. MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND VICTIMS
ADVOCATES TO SEE A SEIZE IN
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. AT LAST YEAR'S
MEASURES- AS LAST YEAR'S
MEASURES WHAT WAS INTENTIONALLY
FLEXIBLE FOR COUNTIES TO CHOOSE
WHICH ENTITIES PARTICIPATED IN
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS THERE
WAS INSTANCES OF CONFUSION
SURROUNDING THE ROLES HE SEES
PLAY WITHIN THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS AND WHAT
INFORMATION IS SHARED. THIS
MEASURE CLARIFIES THESE
ESSENTIAL ASPECTS TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN'S PROTECTED UNDER
THESE TEAMS RECEIVE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE CARE IN ADDITION
TO THE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE WE
WERE HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
TRIBAL FAMILY ADVOCATES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES EXPERIENCE IN THE
CASES OF INDIGENOUS CHILDREN
ABUSE CASES. AB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN PROVIDES CLARITY FOR
THOSE ESSENTIAL TEAMS WORKING
ON SOME OF THE MOST DELICATE AN
URGENT ISSUES FAMILIES IN OUR
STATE FACE ON THE PHONE WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ERIN HARPER WITH- KELLY. KELLY
CALLED. THANK YOU. OKAY VERY
MUCH OF THE SUMMER OF RUBIO-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE AND HER PER- FROM KELLYCO-
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND- DO YOU FOR TWO
MINUTES THREE MINUTES. THREE
MINUTES AND YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
MISS HER SO MUCH BOB. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS ERIN HARPER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALICO
THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER
ALAMEDA COUNTY AS WELL AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTERS OR C. ACC ARE MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN ARE
ORGANIZATIONS DESIGNED TO
REDUCE TRAUMA TO CHILDREN
INVOLVED IN CHILD ABUSE
INVESTIGATIONS AND TO INCREASE
THEACCURACY OF THE
DOMESTICATION. YOU ARE BY TO
THE CHILD VICTIM A BILL TO
RETRIEVE JEFF. IN THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURES SOME
ARE GOVERNMENT BASED ON HOW THE
TRUTH IN A COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OR SOCIAL
SERVICES. OTHERS ARE HOSPITAL
BASED AND MANY ARE STANDALONE
NONPROFIT- IDEA DOCTOR ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO THE WHICH STRUCTURE
BEST SUITS THEIR COMMUNITY
NEEDS. AACR DEFINED IN PENAL
CODE SECTION ELEVEN ONE SIXTY
SIX POINT FORWARD WHICH STATES
IN PART THAT QUOTE EACH COUNTY
MAY USE THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTER TO IMPLEMENT A
COORDINATED MULTI DISCIPLINARY
RESPONSE. PURCHASING LANDS TO
SECTION EIGHTEEN NINE SIXTY ONE
POINT SEVEN OF THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE- DESPITE
THEIR CRITICAL ROLE IN CHILD
ABUSE INVESTIGATIONS. THESE ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE LIST OF
AGENCIES EXPLICITLY STATED IN
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION EIGHTEEN NINE SIXTY ONE
POINT SEVEN. THAT YOU
REFERENCED IN THEIR DEFINING
LEGISLATION. OTHER ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF AGENCIES. WE STAYED
IN THIS SECTION TO SHARE VITAL
POLICE INFORMATION WITH THEIR
SEEKS TO PARTNER OFTEN
CONDUCTED A FORENSIC INTERVIEW
THE CHILD ABUSE VICTIMS. AMONG
COUNTIES AND IS DETERMINED BY
THE COUNTY ATTORNEY APPROACH
INTERPRETING SECTION. WHILE
SHE'S SEEDS HOUSING GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND HOSPITALS ARE
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THIS
DEFINITION DOES SHE SEEMS THAT
ARE STANDALONE NONPROFITS ARE
NOT. READ DIFFERENCE CREATE
INEQUITIES ONLY BASED ON THE
ORGANIZATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
STRUCTURE OF THE CDC. THE LACK
OF INFORMATION SHARING ABILITY
ON THE PART OF NONPROFIT FECES
IN PEAK PROFESSIONALS ABILITY
TO SHARE IMPORTANT MATERIAL
COOLEY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
INVESTIGATE A CHILD ABUSE
ALLEGATION. INFORMATION SHARING
IS VITAL TO. FORMING THE BEST
QUALITY SERVICES FOR A CHILD.
INFORMATION SHARING IS NEEDED
PRIOR TO A FORENSIC INTERVIEW
OF CHILD ABUSE VICTIM NECESSARY
TO PROVIDING THE APPROPRIATE
FOLLOW UP SERVICES INCLUDING
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL AND
THERAPEUTIC CARE AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN A MONTHLY CASE
REVIEW TO ENSURE THAT NO CHILD
NEEDS FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WILDEST MALL IT WILL HAVE AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT ON CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA IMPACTING SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. FECES WHICH ARE
NONPROFIT STRUCTURES THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN COUNTIES WITH A
COMBINED CHILD POPULATION OF
THIRTY MILLION CHILDREN. ACTION
WILL ALSO ALLOW POLICE TO
INCLUDE TRAVEL PROFESSIONALS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO VERY%
MUCH APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
BUT I'LL MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY WILL
BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SEEN ON ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEE NO ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A BI FOR SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE A FEW
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR FOUR FOUR EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN BEFORE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO ONE SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HOLLY FLEMING I'M A FORENSIC
INTERVIEWER AT A CHILDREN'S
ACTIVITY CENTER AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. EXLINE. FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SAN MATEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AS A
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY WITH ERIN REGAN
SAYS IT'S ON BEHALF OF PORAC IN
SUPPORT OF ALL. THANK YOU
EXLINE. ANOTHER PARTICIPANT
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU I THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION WE
DO NOT HAVE A REGISTERED LEAD
OPPOSITION- WITNESS SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO-
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION STARTED THE ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SEEN ON ROOM
FOR TWO OR THREE LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROOM
TO FOR TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN AGAIN IT'S NAME WAS
A POSITION ONLY. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR A BEFORE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. INITIAL OPPOSITION FOR
AB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. SURE THERE'S
NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR
THAT'S NOW MOVES TO THE
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NONE IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY US SENATE CORTESE
MOTIONS TO PASS SOME RUBIO
WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES THANK
YOU JUST SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AGAIN
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU I THINK
IT'S GREAT BILLS. ALL RIGHT SEN
SECRETARY- CONSULTANT- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND AGAINST THE
MOTION HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SECRETARIES IN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS. AB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN HER
TADO. JONES CORTESE HI IT HAS
THE I. COM MARKER. PAN HI AND I.
OKAY WE ARE AT THE CURRENT
LOTUS TWO ZERO HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THE L. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NOW LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEMS
THE NUMBER. SIX EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR BY SUMMER BENNETT
WELCOME. AS YOU ARE CERTAIN THE
CHANCE TO CLEAN THE PODIUM FOR
YOU THERE. OKAY WELCOME CENTER
BENNETT. OUR WELL AWARE THAT-
FOSTER CHILDREN SUFFER- LAGGED
BEHIND THEIR PEERS IN HEALTH
AND EDUCATION OUTCOMES AND FOOD
SECURITY AND IT HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPETE FOR JOBS
AND- MAKE THE TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD WHAT WE MAY NOT ALL
BE AS AWARE OF IS THAT FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF CALFRESH AT THE
PERCENTAGES THAT THEY SHOULD
BASED ON THEIR ECONOMIC
CONDITION. SO WE HAVE A FAIRLY
FORMALIZED PROCESS FOR
TRANSITIONING FOSTER CHILDREN-
HELD A AND THIS ADDS THAT STEP
OF MAKING THEM OFFICIALLY AWARE
OF THE BENEFITS OF CALFRESH I
THINK IT'S FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD- AND BENEFICIAL
PROGRAM I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH- THAT S. CI YOU AND
THE- WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND- DEALT WITH
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAD. AND I AM PLEASED THAT THE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS A
LIBBY SANCHEZ WITH THIS YEAR
YOU AND PAULA HVALER CONSERVE
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
MODERATOR- PLEASE BRING ON TO
THE LINE LIBBY SANCHEZ FROM
THIS YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA AND
KELLY BROOK'S LYNSEY FROM
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION JUST FOR A
WITNESSES SUPPORTED MAKE NOTE
THAT THIS HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT SO. IF YOU WISH TO KEEP
YOUR MARKS- BRIEF- THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED BUT YOU DO HAVE
IF YOU WISH A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES- SO. WE CAN BRING THIS
CALL PRESS NINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER MY TERROR MEMBERS
LED THE PANTHERS ON BEHALF OF
AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING BOTH COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SOCIAL WORKERS
AND COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKER
PARENT SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONE
OF THOSE SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
CHANGE BILLS BUT IT SURE TO
MAKE A BIG IMPACT IN THE LIVES
OF FOSTER YOUTH AS THEY
TRANSITION OUT OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES TO SOME OF THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THERE'S A REAL
PROBLEM WITH FOOD INSECURITY-
IN THAT PARTICULAR POPULATION
AND IT'S A VERY EASY FIX TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THEY ARE AWARE
OF- THEIR POTENTIAL ELIGIBILITY
THAT THEY ARE MADE AWARE OF THE
PROCESS TO APPLY FOR CALFRESH
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS A LIFELINE
TO THOSE WHO RELY ON THE
BENEFITS- FOR THOSE REASONS AND
MORE DEPORT WERE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE CHANGE OF THE AUTHOR-
TOOK TO THE BILL TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT. THANK YOU LIST NOW ON TO
K. BROOKS LOW FROM CALIFORNIA
WILL FOR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAN AND
MEMBERS ACTUALLY CALL THE CALLS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BALL THEIR DIRECT. REPORTS
RECORD AB. THANK YOU FOR. BUT
REQUIRED COUNTY DEPARTMENT
RECORDS THEY'VE PROVIDED NOTICE
TO QUALIFYING YOU TODAY MAY BE
ABLE TO RCEIVE BENEFITS HOW TO
APPLY FOR THE BENEFIT. SERVICE
DEPARTMENT HAD UNTIL TRAVEL
BACK. INCREASE THE
PARTICIPATION POLITICAL FACTOR
YOU. CALFRESH PROGRAM CALPERS
APPLICATION. LAKE EVERYTHING
OVER THE DECADE BOTHERS
INCREASINGLY HURTING THE EARTH
I COULDN'T PROPER CARE WITHOUT
APPLYING FOR OR RECEIVING
PROGRESS. WHAT CODIFY THE
IDENTIFIED. HELP THIRTY AB OUT
OF THE POCKET CARE ACT THEM
THANK YOU TO THE I. FOR
CARRYING THE AND COMMITTEE
CONCURRENT OF THE NUMBER WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ABOUT.
THANK YOU THREE- NOW THE WOMAN
ON TO OTHER WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY
FOUR- BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE SEEN ON ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX SEVENTY FOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU FOR TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WAS START OUT WITH
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AT SANTA CLARA AND
VENTURA COUNTIES HERE IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTY NEXT LINE. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP EVERYBODY ELSE COULD
HIT ONE ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXLINE. THE FINAL REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUING UP AT THE STOP SKEWS ME
ONE JUST IT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AS WE GET ON THE LINE NUMBER
PLEASE PRESS R. ONE ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
SEVENTY FOUR FOR ANYBODY ELSE.
AND WE'LL GO TO. LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO ME TO
SEE WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER TO
BOW TO SHOW SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND- MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT
THANKS FOR MUCH MODERATOR NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD- OPPOSITION WITNESS TO
TESTIFY. SO WE WILL THEN GO TO
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SAYING NO
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN ON ONE TWENTY FORTY. LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO PEOPLE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SIX SEVEN FOUR. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
MODERATOR
THE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CASING
NANZER MOTION. OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SERRA COM LONGER- ALL
RIGHT SO AGAIN THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
SUMMER BENNETT I JUST LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. SO CONSULTANT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS BEEN MADE BY STARCOM MARKETS
TO PASS THE FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SIX
SEVEN FOR HER TADO JONES
ATTENSITY AYE CORTESE AYE CALL
MARKER I FROM LONGER AYE PAN HI
AND BYE. OKAY TO BILLS
CURRENTLY THREE ZERO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANKS VERY MUCH
THE NUMBER VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM
ACTUALLY IS OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR DOUBLE
CHECK THEIR- WE HAVE THE RIGHT
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
SIX BY SUMMER MAIENSCHEIN IT'S
A AS AMENDED- WE ALSO HAVE-
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
FORTY BY DECEMBER ROUTE
ROBERT RIVAS. AND ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWELVE EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE IS THERE A
MOTION. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTCOM LONGER- CONSULTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MOTION IS
TO ADOPT THE CONCERT ADOPTED
CONSENT CALENDAR HER TADO.
JONES CORTESE. CORTESE I'D CALL
MARKER HI FROM LONGER AYE PAN
HI AN HIGH OKAY THREE CURRENTLY
AT THREE ZERO WILL PUT ACCENT
CALENDAR ON CALL ALL RIGHT SO-
ACTUALLY LET'S GO AND GO
THROUGH THE- BILLS SO TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO ADD TO CAST THEIR
VOTES WHO ARE HERE- ACTUALLY IS
THE ONE HERE WHO DID ONE ITEM
NUMBER ONE I THINK SO THOUGH
BUT L. OKAY LET'S GET WELL IT'S
GONNA GO THROUGH ORDERED THAT
WAY LET'S GET THROUGH THESE
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR FIVE BY SUMMER
CALDERON- CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES CORTESE HI CORTESE I'D-
OKAY SO THE GRAVERT IS
CURRENTLY FOUR ONE WILL KEEP
THAT BILL ON CALL LET'S MOVE
OUT TO ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY SUMMER
CALDERON. I CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
PARTISI HI FOR TENNESSEE I'D
CALL MARKER HI. KAMLAGER FIVE.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
ZERO. OKAY LET'S ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY AT. TEN OH FOUR BY
SUMMER CALDERON CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO KAMLAGER HI CAMARGO BY.
OKAY OKAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY-
THREE ZERO THOUGHT THAT LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
HER TADO JONES JONES FIVE COM
MARKER AT THE LOADING. KAMLAGER
NOT VOTING. THANKS TO ALL THE
ABOUT WHAT'S THE COUNT WHAT'S-
OKAY TO THE BILL'S CURRENTLY
THREE ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL AND THEN ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY
SUMMER BENNETT'S. CONSOLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS PORTATO JONES. JONES
FIVE. PHOTO OKAY THAT BILLS
TWENTY FOUR ZERO LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL AND FINALLY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- CONSULT THESE
CALL THE ROLL THAT'S MEMBERS.
APARTADO JONES JONES BY OKAY
DURKAN'S CURRENTLY THE VOTES
FOR ZERO LEAD TO CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL. OKAY I THINK
WE GOT TO SO I THINK THAT
EVERYTHING UNTIL THE CHECK
COMES BACK. S. W. FOR- BOND
WILL GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
FOUR FIVE FIVE SOME RECALLED
AROUND KEEPS UP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES
JONES. FIVE OKAY SO THAT BILL
IS OUT FIVE ZERO. OKAY.
OKAY
SHUTTERS ROLL THROUGH THE ROLE
DO YOU WANT TO DO THAT ADAM
CHAIR OKAY ALL RIGHT SO-
CONSULTANTS LET'S RE OPEN THE
ROLE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TEN OH FOUR BY
SUMMER CALDERON- SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS WERE TO
HER TADO I PER TITLE HI. OKAY
SO- THAT BILLS OUT FOUR ZERO
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM THE
BEFORE A BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TADO HI
FURTADO I'D- OR OKAY THAT THAT
BILL IS OUT FOUR ZERO LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER BENNETT- CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
FOR TITLES I. FOR TITLE II.
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO AND
FINALLY WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- CONSULTING'S CALLED
ROLLED ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO
I FURTADO AYE. XCENT CALENDARS
OUT FIVE ZERO HOW NOW PASSED
THE GAVEL BACK TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU ARE CENTER DR PAN-
FOR TAKING TAKING ME HERE WHILE
I PRESENTED A BILL AND ASSEMBLY
HEALTH- I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
CREATE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION I THINK THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED TODAY'S AGENDA THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
IS NOW ADJOURNED.